thank you for joining me and welcome to
this talk on
adversarial attacks on llms so I'll go
ahead and share a link to
the slides
and that you can follow along
so yeah with that I'll give a brief
introduction of myself so I am a
software engineer with experience in an
intersection of high performance backend
systems
data and machine learning I have great
interest in improving
accessibility and building more
inclusive technology which improves
experiences for people with disabilities
I also double in other things in the Tex
space including rating technical blogs
and contributing to open source with
that brief introduction of me I'll let's
move to our main agenda so in this talk
I'll I'll focus on four main areas areas
so we will talk about what adversarial
attacks are see some examples to get a
better understanding then we will
explore how they're done and why we
should be concerned about them and
finally we will
cover defenses that you can use to
protect your model so let's go ahead and
Define define adversarial attacks so an
adversarial attack is an attack on a
neural network where a subtle carefully
designed peration to the input leads to
an incorrect prediction while the
original input is still classified
correctly that is if you're using a
class like if our neural network is a
classifier but this would be this is
applicable to other neural networks so
that is the perab input will be in will
produce an incorrect output while the
original input is still gives a correct
output so although the change may be
invisible to the human eye the change
that we introduced to the P input the
model considers this change significant
enough to change its prediction so the
concept of adversarial attacks is not
new and we can we can say this from as
far back as 2004 where researchers
showed how traditional machine learning
models could be fooled and in 2013 2014
the topic gained momentum as more
researchers showed how deep deep
learning models were also vulnerable to
adversarial attacks so since then there
have been great advances in the area
where researchers have demonstrated
different types of adversarial examples
and how they fo models so let us first
go through an example of an adversarial
attack in computer vision for Simplicity
so that we can move to an example in the
llm
space so for this here in this example
the classifier can classify the input
image as a cut with high confidence and
it would be indeed correct then when we
add some noise to the input image the
classifier predicts that the image is a
dog this is yeah this could be a bit
puzzling and funny because we can
clearly see it's a cut
and the noise the noise introduced does
not make us think that the image is
anything else other than than a cut I
think even the the the I mean the second
image still looks like a cut even if the
model would classify it as a dog so the
PAB input which is classified as a dog
is referred to as an adversarial example
so you may be asking yourself why did
the model change its prediction so the
pabs we we introduced that is the
adversarial pations are carefully
designed to trick the model into making
a different
prediction so let us explore an example
in the natural language processing space
which is the focus of this
talk
so we will use two examples so in the
first example we see that we are using a
sentiment this is a sentiment analysis
model and the classification model was
fooled into misclassifying sentiments by
just changing one word in the sentence
so the original sentence is perfect
performance by an actor and that it it
it gives a correct prediction that this
is a positive sentiment then in the
adversary
example we change perfect that the word
perfect to spotless and so the second
sentence is spotless performance by the
actor and the model for some reason
predicts this as a negative sentiment
with
100% um confidence in this prediction so
semantically we can see that this
sentence has not changed and
communicates the same idea but the model
takes that word like that one word makes
a big difference to the the model and
makes it change its prediction then in
the second example here we have two the
the sentences appear to be the same but
the model so for example in the first
sentence we have send money to the
account 1 2 3 4 and then the for the the
this is what a human sees and then in
the the model the the input that will be
sub to the model will be send money to
the account U plus two that sequence of
numbers which is imperceptible to a
human so there is imperceptible noise
added to the sentence and this causes
the model to change its output here the
task is to translate from English to
French and so this attack is quite
clever in that the characters added to
the input cannot be perceived by a human
so basically if you saw this sentence as
an input to your model you would not
suspect it as being an adversarial
example or even as an attack to your
model you'd probably just process it
only to realize it was an adversarial
example yeah then having seen this
examples you might be wondering how do
attackers achieve this and how are they
able to determine which word or which
imperceptible character would trig a
model so yeah let's explore that in the
next part of this
talk so adversarial attacks on neuron
networks can be done through different
approaches so this talk I'll focus on
grent M attacks and grent M attacks are
white box models so let's back up a
little and yeah so what are white box
attacks so in a white box attack the
attacker knows the model architecture
the model's parameters and the training
data set so with this knowledge they can
design uh an effective adversarial
attack and for this kinds of attack
attacks are easy especially on open
source model s where this information is
easily available and so someone can rely
on the gradient to find a way to make
those changes to the input then as you
guessed of course there are also
blackbox attacks and here is where the
attacker does not know the models
architecture and relies on the output to
design an attack so this would be a
closed Source model where you only
receive maybe you send an input for
example if it's a sentiment classifier
you send some sentiment or right a
prompt and then whatever you get back
you based on those outputs you will
design your attack based on those
outputs but you don't have any of the
you don't know the model architecture
and you also don't know the weights you
don't know the gradients that kind of
information is not available to
you yeah then uh let's move to how gent
I mean how adversarial attacks are
generated so Gent attacks are based on
the idea that we rely on grent descent
during training so while training a
neural network we're usually trying to
reduce the loss function by updating the
weight basically we're trying to find
what change in the weight decreases the
loss function so here we're trying to
like after we've done uh the initial
with the initial weights you've
introduced to the to the to the model
you try to find whether the bit the the
loss how you can decrease the loss
function by changing the weight so on
the other hand in an adversarial attack
what you're trying to do is to determine
how a small change in the input can
increase the loss function so the
attacker tries to perform a grent GED
search over the tokens and generates
trigger sequences which when appended to
the input will generate an incorrect
output making that that way they able to
fool the model so for instance in the
previous example we've seen that the
triggers are those imperceptible
character those those would be the
trigger sequences that the attacker was
able to find through brient descent and
through simply searching over
the basically following a gent gued
search over what tokens would help
increase the loss
function then so the next thing you'd be
wondering Okay so we've talked about
what adversarial attacks are we've
talked about how they are done and the
other thing would be okay I know all
about this how why should I care about
this or why should we be concerned about
this so with the increasing adoption of
llms in the in real world applications
we should consider the security and
safety of the models I think for
instance we've seen that llms have been
integrated into various Industries for
example in finance you find that people
use them for sentiment analysis on
financial data I think one good example
would be the Bloomberg GPT and if an
attacker can design an adversarial
suffix that can change the model's
prediction from positive to negative or
negative to positive then clearly this
would have a significant effect on
financial decisions from some people and
this could make a this could have an
overall effect in the stock market I
think when it comes to security you just
need an attacka who is motivated enough
to cause chaos and with no time can
explore these kinds of vulnerabilities
that are already known then the other
thing about adversarial attacks is that
researchers have shown that they are
transferable so when someone finds an
attack that is effective for example on
an open source model that that is
performs a white box attack this attack
can be used and can be transferred to
other closed Source H models and they
are quite effective I think I believe in
the references you'll see in one of the
papers that they've shown
how simply designed adversarial attacks
are quite effective even on models where
they did not have access to the models
architecture then with the knowledge
that this the models that the attacks
can be transferable to other models I
think it is quite wise for us to care
about how our models can be more robust
and how we can improve their performance
against adversarial
examples so this talk would not be
complete without talking about defenses
and how you can protect your model from
this known
vulnerability so one of the ways and one
of the most effective ways you can use
to protect your model from adversarial
attacks is to always sanitize input from
users don't just user input and do
checks to ensure that input that the
user provides you conforms to what your
model can handle so for example
as we've seen in the initial example
that someone can just can the input
could not might not have perceptive like
you cannot see the adversarial that is
an adversarial example but if you
sanitize the input and ensure that it
conforms to what your model can handle
and what you've designed your model to
handle then you're able to we out that
attack even before it's it's processed
by your model so you can also explore
paraphrasing the input
through which you but this this should
be used in conjunction with other
methods because it might not be as
effective and it is also important to
note that paraphrasing could result in
model performance degradation
because your model might
not perform as it would have with the
initial input that the user gave then
the other effective way to defend your
model against adversarial attacks is
adversar adversarial training so this
involves training the model with
adversarial examples and this enables
the model to generalize well even when
it's given an adversarial example it's
still able to make a correct prediction
because you've trained it it's already
seen this kind of data before so it's
able to give a correct prediction and it
doesn't it's not fooled as easily as
having not seen any adversarial
examples yeah so you will use the
adversarial examples as part of your
training data set
uh one I think key thing we should note
about adversarial training is that this
could be quite expensive because it
requires high computational power to
generate the adversarial
examples so yeah we we can we've seen
that adversarial attacks are carefully
designed perturbations added to inputs
that trick neural network into producing
incorrect
input so LMS are vulnerable to this
attacks and attackers can design an
attack that is also effective on other
models while deploying your models you
should be wary of potential attacks and
use defences such as sanitizing user
input and and adversarial tuning to make
your models more robust so I think one
of the main the main thing you should
care about here is that one that
adversarial attacks are transferable to
other models so this should be something
you should be even while using open
source models and while leveraging other
llms out there and integrating them in
your system you should be wary that
attack on basically ATT tax designed for
other models could be used to exploit
your model so you
should probably implement one of the
defense uh mechanisms we've talked about
so that being said I hope you've learned
something from this talk or at least it
speak your interest in Security in
machine learning and yeah you can go
through the papers in the further
reading section
and to get a good grasp of how the
attacks are implemented and also just to
find out what other researchers have
been up to in the field of adversarial
attacks uh yeah so thank you for your
attention in time and feel free to reach
out to me on linked to talk about ml
accessibility and software engineering
in general please let me know if you
have any
questions yes I think questions oh yeah
thank you so much I think there are a
couple of comments in uh in the chat
that maybe you have a moment to to read
like yeah I think we have time so I see
I'll just show
this okay
okay is it showing up on stage no it's
not so the first one was can you see it
there in the
chat maybe you could just read it out so
that we are sure yeah so I from suit he
he asks um you will probably be covering
this but looking forward to learning
about how to compute the adversar
perturbation to do this
um was that something that was covered
so I think yes we've covered how the
Gent descent how we how we leverage a
gent descent to Define I think I'll just
go back
to okay yes but we've we've covered this
and I can give a a more detailed
explanation I think afterwards if he
doesn't feel we've properly covered this
great thank you so I'm not seeing any
response but sounds like you've covered
it so that's that's I hope um got his
answer
um ah so there you go he he said you did
cover this to some extent but it seems
like it would work only in the binary
case does that make sense by setting the
features to increase the gradient so
thank you that's his
response okay okay I think uh I Su I
think I'd suggest one going through in
the F I've shared the the slides and to
to this so if you go through one of the
papers here you'll find different so
different researchers we use different
approaches but the underlying H the
underlying idea is that we using we'll
try to increase the loss as compared to
when training where we usually trying to
decrease the loss function
when trying to design an adversarial
example we are trying to increase that
loss function but to a certain degree
not completely that we we go off the
mark such that someone can see that
clearly this is uh different this input
is different from what you would expect
yeah so I think employer suit to go
through one of this and also I think
yeah of
in ah okay yeah I see he mentions that
he'll go through the he's looking
forward to the papers so yeah he can get
more info there hopefully and also you
can reach out to me and we can have a
talk about this more excellent thanks
Fise and I think there's just one more
there um are there are are there any
open source tools to monitor or prevent
the adversarial
attacks so I think uh so far what I've
seen are mostly tools to generate
adversarial attacks actually I have not
seen tools to prevent
or Monita
yeah okay thank but I'd be happy to look
into that as well I think yeah but I
haven't seen any any any tools to
prevent yeah great thank you um oh now
we have a question in the Q&A um there
we okay so in your experience would you
say that neural networks or more less or
equally prone to such attacks compared
classical ml algorithms such as logistic
regression decision trees
Etc so I think uh I would say neural
networks are more prone to to
adversarial attacks mainly because it's
easy to leverage the whole grent descent
idea right uh but for logistic the the
Simplicity of uh logistic regression or
basically traditional ml algorithm
things makes them less prone to this but
it doesn't mean they are they they don't
H face this problem they also like I
think you can also generate adversarial
examples that would trick classical ml
algorithms so I think we can I can
answer that I can also add a comment
later on to to Nishan
yeah great thank you so much all right
um are there any more questions from
folks I think that's
there's ah so this one here I don't know
if the comment they're not um it's not a
question but for training llms
using Contra contrastive learning
sentence Transformers uses something
called hard negative mining which is a
good example of this so that's just
someone sharing some some insight there
yeah
yeah it's suit thank you suit